so I'm going through a thing though
being 45 and still a bachelor yeah uh my
feet how do you go on The Bachelor huh
why don't you go on the patch
version of the bachelor which means in
Northeast Philly
I love being with her I I told her not
that long ago I was like we were in the
kitchen she was cooking or something
like that right and I and she was busy
you know what babe I was like
if I could choose to experience nearly
everything with you
I don't even think that's a bad idea I
probably would do it because I just feel
like when we're together I enjoy
everything so much more so I would
choose to just be with you if I could
constantly right and she said
put these two plates on the coffee table
Love sometimes when you're 100 right and
they're wrong you still apologize to
them and I was like no
I'm not doing it